les chroniques d'olivier assayas avec
fin août début septembre le réalisateur
cherche toujours à raconter une histoire
qui s'appuient souvent sur des détails à
priori anodin un nouveau réalisme qui
permet d'abord à ses comédiens de
s'exprimer en toute liberté film que
nous fait découvrir richard trip au nord
de lomé
pour moi c'est des vivants
touche sommes tous vraiment non plus pas
cette confiance
ils vont par deux anciens amants ami
fidèle nouveau couple ils ont la
trentaine ils se cherchent dans la vie
dans l'amour est parfois dans la vie
enfin ou début septembre une année de
rencontres et de rupture et garçons je
t'en prie en soi pas aux règles je suis
pareil mais j'étais tellement parker de
fait là que tu veux revenir à 3000
kilomètres pendant 16 mois
jenny et adrien vont promener leur
complicité fait de confidences et de non
dits adrien l'écrivain que ronge une
maladie mortelle au soir mais si je suis
en vie d'être aigres n'importe qui à un
moment donné de sa vie peut se retrouver
à ne pas savoir bien où il est avoir un
métier un peu floue être entre deux
entre deux amours
de vie entre deux amis ça devienne
qu'est ce que c'est moi qui te propose
non pas du tout fonctionné ça jour après
jour scène après scène le film d'olivier
assayas tisse sa toile et dans ces vies
qui se croisent les amours comme les
amitiés les plus fortes peuvent cacher
bien des amertumes et dire que je suis
un travail alimentaire etc toi tu as
envie de tendre un gars là dedans
maintenant pourquoi tu dis ça mais c'est
bon plusieurs de la chronique et de
l'incompréhension du monde et des choses
qui lui tombe dessus qui fait que ça
malaxe complètement et on voit là on est
changée mais on le sait même pas dans
quelles directions séparées une
direction compléter plus près c'est un
peu con fait cela c'était hyper car ce
que leur nombre a touché exactement mais
là c'est vraiment l'essence réflexion
sur le temps qui passe et son empreinte
sur les êtres ce film est aussi un hymne
à la vie à la vie de tous les jours avec
ses joies et ses douleurs